BACK TO TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK MSNBC
IS FAR OUT DURING THE WEEK.
YOU SHOULD SEE THE WEEKEND.
IT'S PRETTY -- WHAT'S THE
WORD -- EFFERVESCENT.
ON A SUNDAY PANEL, JOY REID
AND HER COLLEAGUES CONJURED UP
A VISION.
WHAT IF AND FOLLOW THE LOGIC
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
IMPEACHED, CONVICTED, AND THEN
SIMPLY REFUSES TO LEAVE
OFFICE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS -- IN ALL
SERIOUSNESS, WHAT HAPPENS IF
DONALD TRUMP, IF HE JUST SAYS
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF I LEAVE THE OFFICE I MIGHT
BE PROSECUTED IN NEW YORK.
I AIN'T LEAVING.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN?
HE KEEPS JOKING ABOUT IT.
BUT DICTATORSHIPS HAPPEN ALL
OVER THE WORLD WHEN THE PERSON
WHO JOKES ABOUT NOT LEAVING
DOESN'T LEAVE.
HE TALKS ABOUT HIMSELF HE SAYS
EVERYONE ADDRESSES HIM AS
"SIR."
HE SPEAKS LIKE MUSSOLINI.
>> IF HE SAID I DESERVE A
THIRD TERM, HE WOULD GET
SUPPORT FROM THE BASE.
THAT SHOULD SCARE EVERYONE WHO
BELIEVES IN THE REPUBLIC.
>> THEY WILL GO TO STREET AND
SAY YES, YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE A THIRD TERM.
>> HE THINKS I'M PARDONING WAR
CRIMINALS SO IF I HAVE TO
OVERSTAY THE TERM, I'LL CALL
ON THE MILITARY AND THEY WILL
HELP ME.
>> THERE IS A SLIDE TO THE
BELIEF IN TOTALITARIAN.
>> IF YOU EVER GET A CALL TO
BOOK THE JOY REID WEEKEND
SHOW, TAKE IT AS AN INSULT IT
IS MEANT TO BE.
IT'S THE LOWEST LEVEL.
SO BE THE CLEAR, A FACTUAL
MATTER SINCE THIS IS A NEWS
CHANNEL.
TRUMP HAS NEVER THREATENED TO
REFUSE TO LEAVE OFFICE IF HE
IS CONVICTED IN AN IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
OF COURSE HE WON'T BE.
HE HAS NOT THREATENED TO
LAUNCH A MILITARY COUP.
THIS IS PART OF THE ELABORATE
FANTASY UNDERWAY IN JOY REID'S
HEAD WHERE THE F.B.I. IS
INVESTIGATING A PLOT WHERE HER
COMPUTER WAS HACKED.
OR WHATEVER.
IN ANY CASE THE FANTASY THAT
OTHERS ARE EAGER TO JOIN.
I GOT WEIRDER THAN WHAT WE
SHOWED YOU.
JOY REID WENT ON TO SPECULATE
ABOUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
TRUMP WON RE-ELECTION BY
HAVING RUSSIA RIG THE VOTES IN
VERMONT.
>> LET'S SAY THAT ON ELECTION
NIGHT IT'S ANNOUNCED THAT
DONALD TRUMP WON VERMONT.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT IS NOT
POSSIBLE.
BUT SOMEHOW BECAUSE WE HAVE
ANOTHER INFLUENCES THAT GET
INVOLVED IN THE ELECTION, THAT
IS THE WAY THAT HE CLAIMS THAT
HE WON THE ELECTION.
WHAT CAN THE PUBLIC DO ABOUT
IT IF THEY BELIEVE THAT THE
ELECTION IS NOT, WAS NOT
LEGITIMATE?
>> Tucker: IS PAYOTA LEGAL
IN SOME PARTS OF THE UNITED
STATES?
APPARENTLY.
DO YOU HAVE TO EAT THE BUTTONS
BEFORE HOSTING THE SHOW?
YOU SHOULDN'T.
IT'S JUST WRONG.
AUTHOR AND THE COLUMNIST MARK
STEYN JOINS US AND HE WATCHED
WHAT YOU SAW.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I LOVED IT
OFF.
BUT I GATHER THAT 37 TOWN
CLERKS IN SMALL VERMONT TOWNS
BELOW, WITH THE POPULATIONS
BELOW 500.
37 VERMONT TOWN CLERKS
RECENTLY ACQUIRED DACHES IN
RUSSIA SO PUTIN MAY HAVE IT
SEWN UP.
JOY REID FINALLY FIGURED IT
OUT.
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
DISTRACTED INVESTIGATING TRUMP
FOR STEALING THE 2016
ELECTION, HE HAS ALREADY
STOLEN THE 2024 ELECTION.
THAT IS HOW SMART HE IS.
YOU KNOW --
>> Tucker: LIKE HOPSCOTCH
THEFT.
HE IS JUMPING OVER THE CURRENT
ELECTION TO STEAL THE NEXT
ONE.
>> YEAH, YEAH!
THEY JUST HAVEN'T, THEY JUST
HAVEN'T FIGURED IT OUT.
YOU SAID, YOU SAID THAT THIS
WAS LIKE THE SALEM WITCH
TRIALS BEFORE THE BREAK.
IT'S ACTUALLY LIKE THE
MEDIEVAL DUCKING STOOL WHERE
IF A WOMAN WENT UNDER THE
WATER AND CAME UP BREATHING IT
PROVES SHE WAS A WITCH.
IF THE WOMAN DROWNED, IT
PROVES SHE WAS INNOCENT BUT
SHE WAS ALREADY DEAD SO IT'S
NO GREAT SHAKES.
THE ONLY EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP
STOLE THE ELECTION IS THAT HE
WON THE ELECTION.
IN THE DEMOCRATS' -- SO THE
DEMOCRATS, SO THE DEMOCRATS,
THE ONLY WAY THAT TRUMP CAN
PROVE HIS TO BE INNOCENT ON
THE DUCKING STOOL IS TO LOSE
AN ELECTION.
THE GUYS HAVE ALREADY BAKED IN
THE FACT THAT HE IS GOING TO
WIN AGAIN AND THEN THEY HAVE
ALREADY LOST IN PARANOID
FEVERS OF HIM STAYING IN
POWER.
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT
BASICALLY THEY COULD JUST PUT
UP AS A TITLE CARD FOR THE
WHOLE HOUR.
YOU SAID SOMETHING A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO.
THE LEFT ALWAYS ACCUSES THE
RIGHT OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
WHEN JOY REID TALKS ABOUT NOT
ACCEPTING THE RESULTS OF THE
2024 ELECTION, THAT IS HER
EIGHT YEARS ON.
>> Tucker: REALLY.
I WONDER HOW THE F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION ON THE HACKED
COMPUTER IS GOING.
I HAVE A NOTE TO FOLLOW-UP.
>> NO, NO.
DON'T WORRY.